the toys come you didn't tell the most
money which i think are basically one
cake forgive me Prince pie with the
title track off his new album he raps
about love and friendship and the
aimlessness of his generation I'm also
soften einfach revolt somehow you have
to find simple words but words that are
strong and get to the point without
becoming vacuous in full of platitudes
let's see it does assume and that's a
really hard thing to do with
german-language charlotte russe claro my
sins are alguns on vaca results d video
clips moody Aston kisses in the Nocti
ariston years mixtape tasveer Martin
vans are leoben's in Las vanishings
attack us do Zack das Venetians ah yeah
for the past 15 years Prince pond has
been capturing the moment and
documenting the world around him with
his hip hop songs ha yeah
Blake was to the bank
I love the people i described on my
album are people I know maybe the kind
of people everyone knows and that's how
a lot of listeners respond they say hey
I know exactly always talking about like
you know and when that happens i think
i've done my job as a lyricist gonna
write a lot about myself too of course i
will not take y'all fighting feel about
me say wow he's doing his job all right
Prince pies latest album storm to number
one in the German charts he does
everything himself publishing his music
and keeping track of all his dates and
appointments but when he first started
out he never dreamed of making his
living as a rapper
hey adds a new phone up to retinol when
i first started rapping it was something
you did for yourself out of rage and
frustration I the details full house he
had to have some soon the one I didn't
have very many friends in school and I
didn't like it on making music was a way
for me to get all that frustration out
of my system but I never thought anyone
would listen to it turns out people do
want to listen to songs like instinct
released in 2006
manito my ass
when they come along
15 albums in 15 years the song ideas
keep on coming
and maybe the best is yet to come
yeah my house is open manuf one of the
victims sometimes I'm out with my
girlfriend and I say just stop talking
for a second i have to write this down
villain or have an idea when i'm about
to go to sleep but then I forget it I
think my best lines have been lost
because i'm too lazy to record them I
sense a follow-up you know how mighty
gary wilson vanessa
Prince pies influences include Bob Dylan
and the Beatles whose warm and
transparent sound he tries to imitate
even built his own analog equipment to
record the new album
his Japanese dog is named penny lane
after the Beatles song but mostly Prince
pi finds inspiration in everyday life
for example on walks through Berlin's
trendy kreisberg district yes I said so
does finishing music writing magic is
like keeping a diary in a busy year I'll
fill up three volumes boring here maybe
half of volume but like most artists I'm
a pretty tragic figure so there's a lot
to write about in paseo de las pampas it
this one compita 32 year old prince PI
says his new album completes the first
third of his life that leaves plenty of
time for more life stories and songs in
the years to come
the gum
I'm is phenomenal
sheikha peers
stop
I